the jurogan experience right now
it's slightly difficult to talk about
weight loss
because i've been obese and now i'm not
obese and i'm
i celebrate not being obese i am much
better
off with the way i have structured my
life
because of having lost weight but
i can't tell anybody else to do that and
i don't even really want to if somebody
wants to be overweight if that's a
trade-off they're willing to
make yeah that's fine with me but i
think for the most part
most of people i've spoken to they don't
want that a lot of people seem to have
goals that
generally line up with mine and then in
talking to them
now there's this diet culture monster in
the room where even that is attacked
because there's a whole new set of
values that are born
that must be enforced and at some point
there's got to be the recognition that
we don't all necessarily have to want
the exact same stuff
yeah there's also so much biological
variability
right yeah the things that would work on
another person just don't work on you
you know yeah including diet you know
there's
oh man arguing about diets is another
great one and this
i i i really like talking about diets
simply because there's
at the end of the day it's so much safer
than politics because there's no
military backing up a diet system but
you know you talk about politics and
it's like we have a [ __ ] military
to force you to do the [ __ ] we want you
to do versus
the other military that's going to force
you the other way but diets it's like
veganism versus carnivore if we're just
talking about weight loss the other
thing
some of these things get into like the
minutia of health
if you've got a guy who's got a 200
pounds to lose
why are we focusing on the minutia of
health i don't know that that's the
right goal if the goal is
just weight loss i don't think these are
the same
these are the same conversations yeah i
think
i mean i think the the variety
there's so many different things that
need to happen to a person to force them
into action
what do you think is the key things is
it
is it inspiration is
is motivation sometimes is it
that you don't want to die or you don't
want to be sick any longer that you're
fed up
or is it being inspired by a guy like
david goggins or cameron haynes or
something like that
for me for the very first time in my
life
i i was thinking about the future
in a way in terms of what i wanted out
of life
versus just like what makes me happy
right this second
and i was seeing a girl who i'm now
married to we have a bunch of kids and
and i couldn't have a better life like
20 years ago if i'd described to you the
life i wanted
in that moment i've way surpassed that
that's awesome congratulations thank you
very much yeah i i like
i have to take a step back occasionally
and go check you out look what you did
yeah that's amazing that's amazing 500
pounds i was not thinking i can be a dad
i can be a husband i could teach
little kids how to do stuff like this
was not part of my i can't i could take
my wife on a hike i could go to the
beach with her and not
you know sit under a towel in the back
because i'm scared of people looking at
me these were
not the thoughts i was having so that's
spark of motivation of like what do i
want out of life
got me just so far because
after an extreme diet when you've
crashed your metabolism and you then
and by the way your body is fighting
against your tooth and nail doing these
things because
this is your body thinks you're starving
to death right you know and he's trying
to slow everything down slowing
everything down
um over long periods you're not just
consuming fat you're consuming fat and
lean tissue like
it's [ __ ] tough all your hormones are
[ __ ] up your your
i forget the name of the hormone there's
a hormone that makes you hungry this is
skyrocketing when you're on an extreme
extremely uh caloric deficit diet and
so then you go to like just eating like
a normal person and you're watching what
other people eat and you're eating this
and you're
[ __ ] putting on weight again like at
a rapid pace and going like this doesn't
make sense i thought i was cured i lost
all this weight
um i i watched a really
fascinating ted talk by a guy named mike
isratel about five years ago four or
five
five years ago and in it and i had tried
i was dead convinced that i was allergic
to carbohydrates and so i was like
i'll never eat a carbohydrate for the
rest of my life i thought you were
allergic to carbohydrates i was
convinced that
everybody yes that everybody was
gluten intolerant that the way that we
made bread in america with all the
ingredients was just poisonous to the
human body i was
totally convinced of this and i watched
this ted talk by mike israetel and
in it it's called the the dietary
landscape of healthy eating and he just
goes over like
just be moderate that's it just like try
to figure out moderation
nothing's poisonous nothing's off like
salt if you have no salt
you can die if if you're if sodium
disappears from your diet you can die
if you have too much salt it can kill
you like there's a
an amount five grams i think at one time
and and this was
i believe this study was done on small
bodies can kill you can be fatal
so is that poisonous or is it necessary
it's both this is food for me
like um the way i was interacting with
food
the idea that i'm a machine like you
you're a car guy
you're not going to put diesel fuel in
your gas car
you're not going to do that because it's
going to break it and and
i had to start really thinking about
food in these terms and going like
i just have a bad relationship with food
a relationship that is giving me an
outcome
i don't want how do i change that like
utterly
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience